did you know you're supposed to wash
your hair brushes
oh my god
so this is the sink before
cleaning the brushes
nice and clear
look at the color of this water from
just two brushes and a roller
so if you're suffering with greasy hair
i think i know the reason why you're not
cleaning your brushes often enough
that is
vile
i've never washed a hair brush so now we
i gotta wash all of them let's go okay
so first things first we need to take
the hair out of the brush
oh my god
i've been brushing my hair for 28 years
now and i've never considered cleaning
my hair brush so i mean better late than
never so we're gonna need a bowl
brushes
some
clarifying shampoo
and a little bit of dish soap
i'm gonna fill it up with some
hot water
and we're gonna let this soak for a few
hours
i would have never considered cleaning
my hair brush and i don't know why like
now now knowing that i'm supposed to
clean my hair brush it makes a lot of
sense but i would have never considered
cleaning my hairbrush
you learn something new every day on the
internet you know
all right it has been a few hours
probably around like three hours
and
this water is so gross
okay
look at the water in this bowl
like this
i mean the brushes
the brushes look great there's still a
little bit of hair in there i don't know
how exactly to get all the hair out but
look at all that it's like oil it's dust
it's hair it's just
so many different things and it's
honestly pretty gross
but i would have never have known that
my brushes were this dirty
i'm gonna do a final rinse of these
brushes and see what the water looks
like
when i dump it out
if you've never cleaned your brushes
because i know i didn't even know that
you should be cleaning your hair brushes
please do let me know how it goes are
your brushes as dirty as mine apparently
were i i don't know
[Music]
you